hi everybody welcome to another episode
of ask mr. wonderful now this week we
got a deal with the 10,000 pound gorilla
in the room and and there are 30 million
plus people out of work right now
it's extraordinary unprecedented and and
the majority of the questions have to do
with that
about being laid off about what to do
next about businesses that have
basically collapsed I mean I can't
answer all these questions but what I'm
gonna try and do is take a few here that
I think you know address a lot of issues
I mean it's heartbreaking to read this
stuff it's just brutal and and I get it
I get it but you know these are
unprecedented times what do you do when
you have to shut down an economy but at
the same time let's address it well I
want to give some advice on how to
communicate to people when you're
looking for employment I mean because
that's really what these questions are
about how do you do that you know and I
look at dozens and dozens of resumes
every day I mean people are sending me
stuff you know and and also for all the
companies I'm an investor in and by the
way they're hurting too it's not like
it's a free lunch for anybody here but I
want to talk let's let's deal with this
one andraia
cuz this was a good one it's short sweet
right to the point just got laid off
even though my company got PPP two weeks
ago I did all the social media I worked
with all the online platforms to
generate sales and now I have no job
what should I do to think that that's
not an essential job in in this in this
world is a huge mistake what's happening
now is companies that had retail
operations of obviously have to shut
them down and it's more important than
ever to be able to reach out and
communicate directly with the customer
so in this case let's talk about andreia
trying to get read and redeployed
re-employed so here's the things that
matter the most if you have a skill that
she was running social media sounds like
and let's make the assumption that Andre
is good at what she
I mean you have to start there I'm
always an optimist about people because
otherwise why would they have kept her
during good times so she knows what
she's doing
here's here's the way to get re-employed
in this incredibly hard time first of
all I know it sounds mundane but you
have to keep your resume current you
know who are you but it doesn't have to
be fifteen pages I keep telling people
never make it more than three paragraphs
nobody's going to read more than that in
fact the first few sentences are the
most important because there's so many
people looking for work start with
LinkedIn although it matters on every
platform but I'm just saying LinkedIn
right now is getting inundated with
people putting up their posts about who
they are and how they can fix things so
number one is draft three paragraphs
that's one page on who you are and why
you can help a business what is it about
you that is so good that someone would
want to take you with and I believe me
you're competing with a lot of other
people but in the first sentence
something like I increased online sales
for the company I just got fired from by
400% in two quarters it's gotta be a lot
it's got to be a grabber it's got to be
what it's not like where I went to high
school and my dog's name was Kippy and
and I was you know I coached soccer no
one gives a [ __ ] this is an
extraordinary time what they want to
know is what can you do for them now to
help their business now what can you do
right now to help an extraordinarily
difficult situation so it's always about
I can help you generate revenue I can
solve your IT problem I can do this I
can do that but it's direct in the first
sentence about you number one number two
and look you may not like this but
there's so much competition there's so
many people unemployed that you have to
be ready to work for free for a while
now this is a trick that I learned over
in Europe many people in Europe are
what's called apprentices and they come
into a company to prove their net worth
they come in to show that they can do
something you need to do the same thing
think about this
you're already fired you're sitting on
the sofa you're doing that anyways what
if you could
stay in your home and work online for
somebody to prove that you can increase
sales in the case of Andre I hear this
idea of of showing a company you know
obviously you have to scan to try and
find who that is in your local region
I'd suggest do it in case they even want
to meet with you but you might as well
go nationwide at the same time because
you basically to be a digital assistant
and say look give me 30 days for free
I'll work for free for nothing Jana let
me show you what I can do for you for
just 30 days let me show you how I can
actually help you drive sales if you can
do that if you in her case if she's
really good on social what can she do
for a business any business to show that
she can help it for 30 days that gets
you in the door that's what you need
right now the ability just to show your
net worth to somebody because once you
become part of the solution they're not
gonna let you go and even if you have to
work for second month for free so what
you're sitting on your ass anyways but
now you're starting to show yourself to
somebody and by that third month maybe
60 days so now they say you know what
this is working can we make you a
contractor can we pay her every week can
we do something that is what I'm telling
a ton of people to do but there's
certain metrics get that resume to three
paragraphs about how fantastic your on
what you've done to help your current
boss or the one that just fired you
number two put a picture of yourself up
there so they connect with you do a
video make it 30 seconds stick it on
that you know that post of who you are
but the most important is you will do it
for free for up to 60 days you will work
for free stop whining about it just try
it once you get in there once your DNA
is in that business once you're solving
problems then I can let you go whether
you're good or you're not either you can
make this work or you can't but in these
times why not take a shot at that don't
make that resume don't make that pitch
about you more than three paragraphs
nobody's going to read it
nobody they're gonna read the first
paragraph so think real hard and if
you're not good at writing connect with
somebody who is okay second piece of
advice keep your network broad and wide
and active don't sit there at home just
watching movies
all day you got to spend at least 20% of
your day reaching out staying connected
with people that you worked with before
keeping your social platform active
that's how when we get out of this mess
you're gonna get a new job even if they
don't hire you back you know that this
word furlough you're seeing everywhere
don't make the assumption they're gonna
hire you back many businesses are gonna
realize well I can downsize as a result
of this opportunity and they may be one
of the people they never bring you back
for I mean they just cut you out that
could happen I mean it's an opportunity
to reboot many companies and they're
going to take advantage of it
unfortunately now you may have a
position that they'll bring back you may
not the other thing to be aware of in
America today is at least 20% of the
people in large and small companies are
going to get the opportunity to work at
home forever as a result many companies
going to cutback in the amount of
commercial you know office space they
use or the amount of retail space they
use America 2.0 is gonna be far leaner
and meaner but in better opportunities
in some cases let's say you're taking
care of an aging parent you're raising
kids or you don't you don't want to
commute you don't want to buy a car you
want to save money that way maybe you're
one of those people and the way to get
that opportunity is to prove that you
can do it now which is why my whole
thing is alright you'll work for free
from wherever you are it doesn't matter
where you are what matters can you solve
a problem I want to read another one and
this one this one really got me because
there's so many restaurants that are
wiped out
hi mr. wonderful I had a fantastic
catering business and a small restaurant
operation 70% of our business was to
corporate we would make those lunches
that they pick up and we did a fantastic
business doing that we knew our
customers wanted lunch every day buffet
style and then all these offices closed
what do I do
I've lost 70% of my business all right
so here's the story she applied for PPP
through her bank and didn't get it but
her payroll company came through and she
got the PPP and that so there's really
two questions there first of all this
interesting information if you are a
small business and this is a small
restaurant with catering now obviously
if 70% of your business is to
corporations for a line
basically because no one's gonna cater
for a night time we're not much
so she was making big lunches in the
boardroom style you know those big
aluminum things and people go and scoop
the lasagna or spaghetti or whatever it
wasn't a salad okay so that's one issue
we're gonna deal with a second but what
I want to say about the PPP a lot of
people are talking about well my bank
isn't giving it to me I didn't get
through I did I got cut off there's
nothing in the PPP rule the payroll
protection program if you have a small
business that says you can only apply in
one bank but she did she went to
multiple banks or in her case the
payroll company now if the many many
different financial institutions
including payroll companies can provide
these loans in this case so she was
smart she went in on your bank but her
payroll company and they came to you
first you're only getting out one loan
it's not I'm suggesting fraud here I'm
just saying you can apply at many
different financial institutions in your
region and maybe one of them will get it
for you
which she got now let's address the
catering business the bottom line is
nobody's ever going to want to see a big
battle as anya that people are putting
spoons into and taking that's all done
because of health reasons people are
worried about the spread of the virus
obviously so the new catering business
which is going to emerge as businesses
open up they're still gonna want to eat
lunch is going to be individual portions
in small plastic containers and here's
how you have to reboot your business if
you're in the catering space and I'm now
speaking to every caterer okay I want to
see on your website how clean your
operations are how cleanliness is now
the number one issue for you I want to
see it scrubbed down I want you to talk
about how when you prepare food the hair
nets are on the full you know whites or
whatever it is you have and how you're
wearing gloves and how you're wearing a
mess you're gonna have to do this that's
the new 2.0 people have to feel
confident and it can't be [ __ ] you
actually have to do this you've got to
be super clean now in preparing because
I just went through this with another in
my portfolio of companies how this has
to work you're gonna offer four
different basic lunches chicken number
one beef number two a full vegan
offering a vegan
Sonia is a good one all right the point
is it's all standard you got to throw a
fish into so you're gonna have a salmon
or me so Cod's very popular too so think
about it your proteins are gonna be beef
they're gonna be chicken they're gonna
be a lasagna perhaps that's it's just
vegan and you're gonna have a fish you
can choose like basically you know soya
salmon or miso Cod or the two that are
really really popular for those lunches
so pick one the reason you're only going
to do four is you need to have
standardized purchasing of your protein
so you let's say you're now gonna
provide catering some companies are
moving back up so then order lunch but
the images of your of your menu are all
the individual containers because that's
how people are going to get them the
salad is an individual container the
dressings in a packet the knife and fork
are already sealed in a plastic package
with the napkin these already existed
before coronavirus all right but the
point is there is no big vat of food
anymore you're not gonna sell that to
anybody you're gonna have to get used to
making individual portions so you
basically let people on your on your
website or even if you're gonna provide
a checkoff menu choose one of those
proteins the salad is standard it's the
same it's a mixed green salad everybody
gets the same thing that lets you
prepare the st. you've got to simplify
this thing all right and the pricing is
going to be slightly higher because
that's gonna be your costs they're gonna
be now individualized but everybody
feels comfortable if they're opening up
their own lunch and it's just basically
their own unique package and the last
time because you can put a little sticky
seal on it that you put your brand name
of your company honor that you prepared
it and you sealed it and it's super
clean that's the only way this is gonna
work so when if you've got 20 people in
a boardroom or its maybe virtual they're
going into the board and to get it and
go back to their area of work which is
more likely gonna happen it's all
individualized this is starting to come
back now there are some companies that
are putting up to five six people at
work even in New York City that's
happening everybody's wearing a mask but
they need lunch and they want to get it
from somebody they know is preparing it
cleanly in a very clean way but it's all
individual packaging so that's how
that's going to work now I want to talk
about a third issue too
and I'm gonna use myself as an example I
was going out of my mind sitting here
the first month I was going crazy and
I've got so many investments that are
suffering and struggling and I thought
what can I do to help them you know I
worked in getting PPP loans I actually
helicoptered money into some places
where I need it to invest to keep them
alive and keep them open because it it
was important for them to do that I'm
gonna give you a couple examples you
know that Korea had 20 years ago 30
years ago I was a construction worker
for a while I put rebar into sin of
cinder blocks I was a bricklayer for a
while these were summer jobs I had
trying to put myself through school in
college I got a job once as a gaffer for
a company that did sports television
they were filming volleyball games and
college football games and stuff like
that and I was slinging beer at nights
to put myself through college and then I
took the job as a gaffer gaffers kind of
person runs around sets up the lights
takes down the cables and all that stuff
but from that business I eventually got
trained how to be a cameraman than a
sound man than a film editor I never
lost those skills I still have them and
many of you are in the same situation
you have things you did a long time ago
they don't leave you it's like riding a
bicycle you remember them forever so I
said okay well maybe I can help my
companies as a as a social media guy I
mean a lot of people know who I am so
maybe I can record my own commercials
right here in this kitchen and help some
of my companies because I know how to
edit I know how to record I know how to
do stuff from those days 20 30 years ago
when I was wasn't when I was doing that
and I never lost my editing skills so I
just got my chops instead of editing on
on a plate steenbeck which was film like
literally film I learned how to use
Premiere Pro and Adobe product it's the
same basic idea it's digital right go
back to your roots and find something
that you can do that you've learned a
long time ago maybe your careers stalled
maybe you're not going to get hired
maybe you want to work what I work as a
bricklayer yeah I know how to do that
but I can make these commercials so I've
been every day I get up in the morning I
say to my companies what can I do for
you
I'll give you an example you know and I
know this is you know maybe you're gonna
say it's crap
promotion for one way companies yeah but
so what it's a great example love pop
greeting cards fantastic company they
had lots of retail stores because when
you purchase when you when you actually
you purchase a greeting card it's often
in a store so we had little stores all
over the malls in America they're all
shut down but the company didn't say oh
it was me they said well what can we do
to direct to our customers which is the
right thing to do you think of it that
way and they came up with an idea for a
Mother's Day which is you know happening
this weekend instead of making a
greeting card they made this flowers
cheaper than ordering real flowers these
are beautiful they're pieces of art and
they said to me hey Kevin can you record
a commercial so I shot this course
understand right now right here in the
kitchen I did it because I know how to
do it and they use them on social media
to help and they sold millions of
dollars worth of these now this is a
fantastic idea and I like to think I
helped also Benjy Locke I don't know if
you remember this deal these these these
locks that you know obviously are one of
our biggest ways of selling it was in
retail and we're not doing that anymore
so what could we do on social media what
could we do so I called my friends at
QVC and I said hey guys
could we try and sell these Benjy luxe I
think everybody in America would like to
have one of these so you know maybe your
bicycle helmet hook it up to your bike
close your purse your duffel bag
whatever it is but it's a great product
and would you let me try and sell it to
rec and then I also said why don't I
shoot some why don't I do something with
what I know socially so now that we're
all quarantined I'm working with all my
companies trying to get stuff out as we
have to switch from retail distribution
now we've got to go back and do online
we have to work with you know Amazon we
got to work with QVC we got to sell
direct so I'm shooting some video now
for one of my companies you may have
heard of called Benji Locke this is a
really interesting technology this is
the first fingerprint lock that also has
a key let me show you the travel version
of it as well
so look at this I mean I'm gonna be
filming this for QVC I'm gonna go live
on QVC with this thing and I want to
show people how you can basically use a
lock like this with your finger and open
it up it's amazing technology see how
that works
but I got to produce some social media
before we go nuts and so what I've done
is I've tried to set up a shot here I'm
using an industrial Lance to actually
get rather interesting image of this
lens going right through the locks so
I've set up a program that says okay
come out for the shot then go zooming
back in and we're gonna get some really
interesting images of these logs that we
can use in the social media for the
whole QVC thing it's a great shot you
can see it right there
yeah we're doing it in the kitchen
that's my whole point and every year the
technology gets cheaper as long as you
stay current with it you understand how
to use it that's the whole key why not
use your skills from you know the past
to create new employment if I can help
my company sitting here you know stuck
in my little studio Miami prison for the
next I've been here two months already
but every day I shoot more stuff and I
try and do as much as I can to help them
out so for Benji Locke it's get this
social media shot cut it post it push
eyeballs to QVC sell locks that's the
plan and the same for all my companies
under that for anybody but the whole
point is use your skill sets from the
past to help your businesses today or
get a job today or do whatever it is you
you have to do because I don't care
every year of your life you're learning
something and you don't forget it you
can bring it back now you know I
remember the gaffer days when I wrap
tape around light poles and then the
editing days and then the sound days and
the camera days well here I am doing it
all over again that's my whole point and
you can do the same thing
[Music]
[Music]
in America 2.0 it may not be the job you
lost that it's going to be the job you
get back it may be a skill you learned a
long time ago and people say well yeah I
I used to sling beer yeah so did I and
if I was really facing dire straits I'd
go back and do that again if and when
we're slinging beer again but maybe some
other skills that you had maybe you were
a copywriter maybe you're a graphic
designer
maybe you were a film editor like I was
maybe you're gonna bring these things
back and by the way I'd rather get up in
the morning and do this stuff than sit
on my ass because you're just gonna get
depressed I don't care who you are how
much money you have or don't have you
have to have a purpose for your day and
it's got to be a routine and I talked
about that a lot last week about routine
and what it takes but now I'm talking
about employing yourself making yourself
useful to others and finding a new way
to make money and and I think in America
2.0 it's those skills that you might
have done decades ago that are gonna
come back and help you whatever it is
redefine yourself find out what you're
good at
put it down on paper and reach out and
offer to do that skill for free for up
to 60 days you know I know people who
say what are you nuts no I'm not nuts
you think about this pandemic can you
imagine this pandemic thirty years ago
and there was no social media when you
would have been isolated in a way we
can't even communicate with anybody
except by a telephone maybe and you
wouldn't know who to dial I mean now you
can reach out to millions of people on
social and yeah there's all lots of
other people doing it but it's it's a
way of communicating we never had and
now it's gonna redefine and by the way
technology's made it easy all of these
these web you know video platforms you
can use to reach out to people I'm kind
of just throwing it at the wall saying
do things that you know you're good at
and make sure you don't spend your whole
day just sitting on your ass watching
movies that is not who you are
that that can be incredibly depressing
I've got hundreds of emails about people
have lost their jobs and you know
somebody's lost their job the key is to
stay healthy if you can and redefine who
you are until next week take care and
stay healthy and stay wonderful
listen to this email I'm getting a lot
just like it dear mr. wonderful my
brother and I have been 50/50 partners
in a liquor and wine store for 18 years
after the virus hit he decided he did
not want to show up to work anymore
but asked me to send him two thousand
dollars a week as an equity owner he
said quote unquote take it out of my
half and we could settle up later my
wife and I are now working 18 hours a
day to keep the store afloat with
curbside service and deliveries to all
the apartments and condos around us this
is a horrible situation because my wife
and brother are now really pissed at me
my brother thinks you're an [ __ ] on
Shark Tank but would trust your opinion
what do you think my next move should be
help us thank you Michael you know I'm
getting inundated with questions like
this just a mountain of them obviously
in the world today there's a huge amount
of disputes and nothing kills the
momentum of business large or small like
a money dispute and in this case family
as well so I've asked my friends at CNBC
to help I mean I can't curate all these
questions but I think the matically
there's some great things to deal with
here so I've asked them to set up a site
they have we're gonna let you post your
video there and I'm gonna answer as many
as I can I know I can't solve all the
problems in the world but I can answer
as many as I can and we're gonna try and
pick the right themes out of all those
so use your phone put it put a video
together make it real easy and go to see
nbc.com slash money dispute let me know
what the issue is I'm gonna try and help
thank you and by the way my friends stay
healthy stay safe take care now I have a
great email here because it gives me a
chance to talk about the five things you
need to know to get higher and and I
think there's gonna be millions of
people over the next six nine months as
things normalized looking for work
because we know there's over 30 million
that have been laid off which is
unprecedented so I think this is very
important information this is from
finola now finola is an irish name i
love that name hi mr. wonderful
my name is finola i'm a controller at a
civil engineering firm accountant
basically
just been furloughed that means fired
yeah I know what that means vanilla it's
not good news before I got laid off I've
been talking to a competitor and they
sounded interested in hiring me for
slightly higher pay so I was interested
now they formalized the process and have
asked me to come in with a resume next
week to do an interview well I think
that's good news can you give me some
tips
yeah finola you've come to the right
place I'm gonna give you five tips and I
want everybody that's interested in
figuring out how to get hired or wants
to get hired to listen to these because
I'm gonna treat it as if I'm hiring you
okay I've done a lot of interviews in my
time these are the things that matter so
let's start with basically this you got
to perfect your resume I don't need to
know the job description of every place
you've ever worked I need to know what
you accomplished that was something the
average Joe wouldn't have done I don't
hire for competence I hire people who
routinely go above and beyond what's
adequate you've got to communicate that
don't leave blank spaces on your resume
that's number two plenty of people have
gaps in their work experience try and
fill your time with things that matter
to you just because you don't know a
full-time job doesn't mean it isn't time
to go and be idle get a volunteer gig or
show your compassion and energy take an
online course show you want to better
yourself I don't like to see gaps in
resume nobody who hires does so be
careful when you're filling it out
you're doing something all the time when
you do the interview number three watch
your body language if you're shaking
your knee nervously or anxiously picking
your nails at a time when we're meeting
how can I trust you to confidently
represent my company in a high-stakes
meeting I like some peace and quiet but
focus on a similar vein this is number
four dress the part it doesn't always
mean a three-piece suit in a hot watch
look if you're in financial services or
something it ties a good idea but if
you're a coder I don't care if you wear
a t-shirt and jeans
it's what the other people are wearing
you don't want to stick out like a sore
thumb okay look you don't need cufflinks
if you're a coder I just want to know if
you can code and number five show me you
know how to plan for yourself and from
my company how does the job I'm hiring
for
fit into your career and life plan I
don't want to hire somebody who who's
there for a one-off in between job or
leaves disappointed that the job I gave
them didn't lead to a career trajectory
they had hoped for I don't want to hire
someone who joins my company and thinks
they're just going to be comfortable in
business is good
I always want business to be great I
want to be growing my staff only knows
how to think ahead good business isn't
good enough we're constantly working and
planning towards being better if you can
communicate that in a job interview I'm
gonna hire you and so is everybody else
so finola good luck stay focused stay at
peace when you're in that interview but
make sure you're explaining to them how
you can make it better for your boss
that's the key to success be thinking
that and good luck
[Music]